now on this program we've given a lot of
time to the issue of young people and
mental health and eating disorders and
tonight we're joined by a young man with
a lot to say about all of that James
McVey is well known as singer and
guitarist with the vamps and now perhaps
even better known for his recent
appearance on I'm a celebrity he's also
open about his experience with anxiety
and an eating disorder and he is in the
studio with me now thanks James
happening in as I say we've done quite a
lot on teenage mental health and the
crisis that just seems to be consuming
young people in this country when did
you begin struggling with your anxiety
or depression or what do you well it
oppression it's difficult because a lot
of press articles that I had anorexia
which i think is isn't isn't true but
what I would say is I've struggled first
I'd say ten years with having a negative
relationship with food and at the start
I didn't really realize just how severe
it was and it began to fester and I was
at a point where every moment of the day
was my thoughts were consumed by what am
i eating when am i eating because I got
it into my head thinking that not eating
was was a good thing for my health
because I wanted to be really lean
muscle II mostly guy and I thought the
only way to do that was he loads and
loads and loads of protein powder but
then nothing else and and it built up to
a point where I realized that I really
my life was being controlled by thinking
of food and and I mean what was the
cause do you think was it just that you
wanted to to look good or was there a
deeper cause what did you ever get to
the bottom of that well it's difficult
for me because when I was growing up
like younger sort of age 10 I was
slightly overweight and then when I
turned maybe 15 16 I rocketed up and and
got thin and I and I was at the time of
there was a there was a few shops that
were fashionable for guys of my age to
wear and all of the models on the
plastic bags were it was in LA in there
you know at six-packs and big chests and
I thought that that was desirable
because all of the the kids in my school
thought that was cool and and it started
where I just had this this sort of
shopping bag in my bedroom that I'd had
from when I bought a shirt and I saw it
every day and I
I want to look like that so it started
actually as me thinking I want to be
health they want to be active and it
sort of slowly transit transitioned into
an obsessive kind of nature where every
dying breath I have was right I have to
have a protein bar oh I can't have that
slice of bread I can't have ketchup on
my food and before I knew it yeah my
life was dominated by by this kind of
anxiety with food and anxiety with food
is conditioned and anorexia is a
condition we normally associate with
girls my daughter had anorexia we made
occu mentary about it so I know a little
bit about it but what I do know about it
is not many boys speak out about it and
young men speak out about it so why are
you willing to do that well yeah and in
the past six years according to a
Guardian asked all men being admitted
hospital for eating sores went up 70% so
it's clear that this is a massive
problem for us guys too and a lot of men
might find it quite difficult to talk
about that because it's quite you're
very vulnerable in that position and I
think showing that vulnerability some
men seem to be embarrassing so I trying
my best to shed some light on my
personal experience with this in the
hope that other people and do the same
and a lot of us guys go to the gym and
we scroll through Instagram and see see
you know bodybuilders and think that's
great and it's that recognition of
understanding that it's not obtainable
to look like that
all the time and that's the trap I fell
in so I thought well if I do this then
I'll end up looking like this and it's
that acknowledgement that actually
that's not a healthy outlook to have on
life and I think a lot of people like me
are feeling that and do you still have a
problem with food it's ongoing and my
might you know it's been probably 10
years I've had I've been dealing with
this and everyday is a constant battle
for me I've still got a long way to go I
know we did a photo shoot yesterday for
the band's new new album and there was
like a thing of chocolates there and all
the boys would just pick him and you
know have him as the day went but I I
wouldn't I wouldn't let myself do that
because I know that if I had a handful
of there might be beating myself up for
the rest of the afternoon and it sounds
so strange saying it but I don't have
moderation in my life so it shows that
there clearly is still a problem there
for me that I'm trying to
address and solve I suppose now one of
the issues I had when my daughter became
ill with anorexia was that I didn't
appreciate that it was a mental illness
yeah it was a teenage fad that she was
going through that she just wanted to
get look better and get stammers she'd
grow out of it
of course she didn't she got
increasingly increasing Neil when did
you accept do you think that it was a
mental illness I think for me have you
accept well that that's the thing I I'm
quite resilient to thinking that that's
it because I look at it still thinking
god I'm being so stupid with this and I
think that's the problem we're still I
mean we're slowly learning that the
importance of acknowledging mental
instability on par with you know
physical injury but I think there's
still a way to go and I think I am still
in denial with it I'm not seeing it is
something as serious as I should but the
reality is it does dictate how I how I
live my life when I'm eating meals what
I'm eating and and yet I but I still
think there is there is a way to go for
me definitely yeah and you've talked
also about your anxiety I wouldn't say
depression because you didn't I don't
know I used the word to pronounce and I
you know many young people now have
anxiety how did that manifest itself and
you know how did you you know talk to
your fellow band members for instance
when it came to your eating disorder and
your anxiety but how did it begin really
I think for me there was a pressure to
maintain control over my life I was very
very lucky and I'm lucky that my job
took me around the world enabled me to
meet loads of people do loads of things
but before I knew it I had been yes
swept away on this journey of at all
that effectively lasted five years and I
was never home for long I was between
hotels which sounds glamorous and it's
amazing but there was that pressure to
maintain that constant hi and I
recognized that the one that many
elements of my life that I could control
but diet was one of those things and
that became like my sanctuary I thought
it was my my release to you know know
that I can take my protein pouches on
tall with me and every morning I can
have protein with my porridge and water
and that was what I did but I realized
that it
that wasn't it that wasn't a long-term
answer to my to my problems and I would
numb down the real issues I had and my
inability to to be at one with my
emotions trying trying to remain
emotionless built up in me and it got to
a point where I was like actually I
don't enjoy doing the band anymore I
couldn't see clearly my vision was
clouded with with all things going on
and I think I needed to
I needed to address things that were
going on within my head and it took me
to breaking point before realizing I
have to be vocal about it and that that
was what was really cathartic for me it
was a breaking point you mean what you
mean you leaving the band yeah so we're
just done we're just done an arena our
second arena tour I mean we just played
two sold-out nights at the o2 and on
stage I was like I want to leave which
which is ridiculous but it just shows
how these mental instabilities for me
weren't rational and yeah you know it
was an incredible thing to do in the
band and I absolutely love being in the
band but these these things that were
going on inside my head were kind of
making me not enjoy that and it was
really bizarre it's like a moral battle
in my head because I knew that I was
being irrational and silly but I
couldn't I couldn't figure out am I here
and I mean you have a big social media
following what role do you think social
media plays not solely in your you know
anxiety and eating disorder but in these
quite serious cases of depression among
young people and teenagers do you think
social media plays a big part in that I
think social media definitely has a big
role in it and we all I think it's
impossible for us to say right let's all
put our finds away now because the
reality is everyone has a mobile now and
whether we like that or not that is
where the future is heading I think that
there's a lot of potentially dangerous
content on there so my personal
experience I I can see clear footsteps
to where I got from seeing the people on
Instagram the bodybuilders you know
portraying this perfect idealistic life
where everything's great and there was
no kind of negativity there it was all
positive positive and it made me think
well why is my life not that that
incredible what why it was putting me
down I was like well why why can I not
you know get to that level and I
if our kids are scrolling and seeing
superstars doing X wines that they're
believing that everyone's journey is
headed into that you know utopian life
and I think that's where we have slight
issues I don't know whether there needs
to be something put in place that we're
where people are saying actually this
isn't genuine this is not the norm yeah
I mean and there's a darker side where
there are these images of self harm and
you know promoting suicide and taking
our own life we had the case of Molly
Russell the fourteen-year-old who did
take her own life do you think something
needs to be done about that kind of
material online do you think the people
like Facebook should be legally there
should be a legal protection I think
there needs to be some form of
censorship because the reality is kids
have phones now and it's very difficult
for parents to to kind of watch what
their children are doing you can you can
access anything at the end of the end of
your hand if you've got a phone so that
there has to be something put in place I
think to to kind of address these issues
you know kids shouldn't be able to see
this content as easily as they are now
because it is pretty easy mmm do you
think there should be tougher laws I
think I think there has to be but it's
it's about it's about figuring out how
to do that because the Internet's not
something that's easy to control so I'm
not sure the actual solution but but
maybe that there should be more
conversation about about that reality
versus not not being real because I
think it's a scary place if our kids
have been brought up thinking that
everything that's say on Instagram is
real because we know suicide rates you
know 15 to 19 you're a certain this
suicide rates are at record levels what
kind of advice would you give maybe to a
young man who is bottling up anxiety and
depression doesn't want to talk about it
in the way that you decided you would
talk about it what sort of advice would
you give that young man it's really
really difficult but I think
communicating is is the key
acknowledging that emotions aren't
something we should subdue but embrace
and I think opening up to anyone whether
you know whether it's a friend relative
whatever that that is the first step
well it
definitely for me for sure yeah and do
you think that enough is being done by
the government James when it comes to
control you know looking after people
with mental illnesses so not not
preventing people getting them but once
they've got them do you think there are
enough resources being put to into young
people's mental health particularly I
think we're getting there I think up
till very recently it was definitely not
on the top agendas for government but I
think that a lot of celebrities coming
forward has highlighted that the
deep-rooted issues within society and I
definitely think we're taking active
steps but as ever more things can be
done for sure right and just finally I
mean if you could say one thing to the
government when it comes to mental
health and and you know a commitment to
treating mental health what would you
say to the people who do have the
resources to you know do something about
this I think we have to continue to
acknowledge mental health on par with
physical health because they are
connected definitely and so I'd say that
that's definitely what we need to
endeavour to do